here with reaction fox news contributor
joe concho along with just the news
founder he broke a lot of these stories
he's the founder and editor john solomon
um didn't the horowitz report also refer
if he really feels that way about people
accused of lying didn't he refer people
like jim comey and andrew mccabe uh to
be investigated for lying uh john
solomon and now that we see
a little bit of getting a little glimpse
into durham's
path forward what do you glean from all
of this
well listen
the entire case was built upon lie upon
lie upon lie dan janko's lighting the
steel steel's got stuff that's going to
hillary clinton hillary clinton is lying
to the american public in late october
when she's peddling this jake sullivan
is out there the entire thing was a ruse
from beginning to end and it's taken us
almost five years to get the bottom of
it but listen the biggest losers in the
durham investigation beyond those who
are indicted are the hillary clinton
campaign they've been exposed for what
they did they ran a dirty trick and they
got the u.s intelligence committee to
participate the news media i'm going to
leave that to my good friend
joe who knows more about it than i but
the news media got taken for an
incredible ride and the fbi there's only
two possibilities the fbi was so
incompetent they failed to see the dirty
trick or they knew and they perpetrated
and allowed it to go on neither one is
good for the american people
uh unbelievable joe concha the media now
or we could do hours and hours of tape
of the media mob cnn fake news msdnc
they perpetrated these lies along with
the likes of the congenital liar adam
schiff
they've never retracted they've never
apologized they've never corrected the
record they've never admitted they're
wrong they've never been held
accountable how do how do you
how do you perpetuate lives like this
for three years
and never come clean to your audience
and then just move on to the next round
of lives
because they don't care it was all a
matter of a means to an end push the
narrative put adam schiff on the air
dozens upon dozens of times adam schiff
is the michael avenatti of capitol hill
basically in the cable news world as far
as cable news being msnbc and cnn an
empty suit adored by the media he even
even get a green room named after him at
cnn and msnbc and kudos to morgan
ortegas for being the first person
considering media to actually challenge
schiff on his russia claims which are
the best unintentional comedy routines
out there remember it was schiff and
this is what morgan pointed out before
who read the juicy obviously farcical
parts of the steele dossier which is
completely unverified into the
congressional record this is the same
adam schiff who swore he had smoking gun
evidence that he saw direct evidence of
collusion between trump and russia he
pushed the steele dossier his gospel the
same way rachel maddow the alex jones of
cable news herself did night after night
and for lying and for leaking and for
misleading the american people he gets
rewarded with a book deal worth i don't
know 100 billion rubles and i'm sorry no
active lawmaker republican democrat no
book deals while you're supposed to be
serving the american people because you
may be trying to weave a narrative that
might not be based in truth in order to
sell books you want to be michael wolf
or jackie collins get out of congress
and go write books instead that's all i
have to say about that hi john solomon
by the way we haven't seen each other by
the way you're almost like mark that's
it i'm not i'm done
i will say this i'm done
that's what he says
it we do not have equal justice and
equal application of our laws in this
country anymore we have a politicized
doj as we speak
and we literally have if you're a
democrat you get one system of justice
if you're a conservative and republican
you get an entirely different set of
justice in america if that doesn't get
solved and resolved we won't have a
country
john joe thank you
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis